[Music]
and welcome back everybody to part two
of the careful boys getting to know Mr
June Lee oh
intimate so what were you just saying
about what you didn't like about New
York what else we start with that that
they got overdressed to do basic like
this gu wearing a tuxedo washing his
car it's kind of Fire
hey what I do like about New York is
they're always on time La people [__]
man what the [__] you don't understand
what time is yeah I feel like in New
York New York you got to be on time like
12 different times to get on time
somewhere cuz you got to hit the right
Subway to the right you know what I'm
saying there's like a [__] 10
checkpoints and that way you always stay
on time otherwise you're like [__] I got
to jump in the cabin that's going to
cost me like 40 bucks so I have to do
this right you know I blame our freeways
and accidents but at the same time if
you've been here long enough you know
how to time it right yeah there just be
like I just going to be there 40 minutes
nah make it 50 and you're there then why
is like Nick always late not always late
I'm consistently off cuz he's coming
from [__] San Bernardino and there's
no direct freeway see thank you for
having my back dog no I tried to go to
Jiu-Jitsu JY we're off the 210 we're off
to 210 but guess what you know how hard
it is to get to the [__] 210 it's
literally 4 minutes from the free yeah
straight shot how do you get to the 210
we got a couple po you got to go up
[__] lost Road blad for 12 miles just
cuz you live in monre Park or wherever
you stay at where there's no freeway
access it took me 2 hours to go to this
Jiu-Jitsu Place sh was crazy La this is
[__] up dude this is this not this
video they're not even that's not even
La yeah I love meeting um people from
like the bay and they're like oh you
don't know San Alana
hro
it's not SF I'm like all
right so he's actually he he lives in
Pasadena like what are oh ni what are
your stereotypes about Pasadena boys I
don't know too much but um just
generalize it's okay I feel like
Pasadena's got monies and like I would
like to live around there not where I
live like to like I would like a goal
Pasadena seems kind of like it's one of
those goals I feel like the whites are
there though there's some
whites it's a pretty
it it's the it's the whites that are not
like the get off my long kind of whites
they're the Subaru whites it's the
whites that go on vacation on the
Summers they go bouldering the REI
whites the bouldering whites bouldering
that's big here yeah the whites of
pasaden are pretty nice actually
generally the whites of Pasad some of
them are like you guys are you guys are
too bad you you guys are too up I want
to be a future homeowner what are some
like cities Las Vegas California just
out of
californ I'm going to take that font
size 72 underline B and then highlight
it
yeah he's right if you compare house
here you need $2 $300,000 for a down
payment just get ready and it depends
how nice you want the house y I want
like right outside the city but I still
want to be close I don't want to be like
completely removed like deep in the
suburb that's what I try to I was living
in Glendora so it's like that's pretty
damn far it's pretty far but that's like
as far as you can go to still be kind of
like you know best bang for your buck
like you get a good house for like a
decent price that feels like you're not
paying like a million dollar for
something that's about to fall apart in
like 2 days yep so we lived out there
but somehow these [__] homeless bums
they can still [__] on my lawn all the
way over there so I have to go all the
way to East Cina where the aerial code
is 702 too so I lived in that part East
K yeah super East super East we're in
East California Baro is where I live
East the homeless people in La the
homeless people in LA are quite powerful
they're they're good at what they
they'll travel anywhere yeah like
they're they're consistently yeah oh
very resilient very resilient so yeah if
you want a house um and you want to be
close to the city the closest you'll be
is probably about an hour what if he's
balling we don't know that if you're
Bing anywhere 20 minutes less than 20
minutes anywhere there's a I mean is it
Outwater village where that little lake
is that area is pretty nice like e park
no no there's a there's a there's
another place that they gentrified the
living life out of
Silverlake Los felis cuz all the
gentrified places are crazy too like
million dollars for two-bedroom home
your house whole thing is slanted y
there's like a gated community up there
yeah yeah your driveway is this big yeah
there's a gated community by the Dodger
Stadium that's a nice place like frog
town area yeah yeah yeah there's like a
there's that's what I don't like about
the like even in the what is it Mount
Washington everyone's driveway looks
like [__] halfpipe yeah yeah it is
crazy yeah it's really it's exaggerated
[__] typ bar in there you can't like
when you're driving up those Hills and
you have to drive super slow cuz you're
not sure if a car is coming this way on
the other side of the
hill so la would you would you would
want to buy a home here cuz your your
your industry is here yeah yeah yeah
yeah when did you come to La 2019 8
months before wow so as soon as you got
here it was like lockdown on your dreams
yep yep so you came out here to pursue
acting and all that dang so what did you
do in in in
between I
started well I went to college in ug at
University of Georgia um I started
advertising and myor
communication um I just I after
graduating I worked at a startup that I
was like whatever I worked at the Apple
Store ohol just done serving job you're
a genius I'm pretty oh no I wasn't a gen
genius bartender yeah yeah yeah I was
like I was a sales in the front Okay but
uh I did that and then I kind of quickly
moved out here this was my dream since I
was four like you wanted to get into
entertainment yeah since I was 4 and so
like it just took I took a very
roundabout approach um I didn't go to
like film school or anything like that
but then like after college I I was like
you know what let me not be a [__] and
just like actually try try this good for
you so how did you actually like get in
the scene cuz like obviously you just
did the brother's son which is like a
freaking what do you think about the
show Joe I thought it was
Asian yeah there's a lot of Asian face
it was Asian amazing you want to know
something about brother son that's
pretty good get what's [__] [__]
is I audition for I didn't even get it
dude that is [__] up for which let me
see I was that's I was trying to look is
that the one that you read for that you
had homie help you out yeah oh no way
you supposed to be a big buff guy a bald
buff guy big ass beat up the bald buff
guy like that's episode one like a buff
gay guy that comes out later on I think
it was because I I auditioned for the
wrong role so on on Instagram I'm a very
like what are the crystals telling me Ty
of do so on my Instagram on my explore
it came up it was like casting call
brother I never auditioned for anything
this comes up I'm like oh dude what's
the world trying to tell
me and then it says like roll like
something something 26y old Taiwanese
guy whatever I'm like oh dude I'm
Taiwanese yeah but you like
48 he was about to kill you did you see
that I was like oh that's me I could do
it so I literally filmed it in that room
you remember which young brother or the
older brother I'm guessing it's one of
those I don't know but I I set up some
light
and then I [__] looked at the the
sides I was like memorized
itah sent it in and then I even DM the
uh casting director she was actually
communicative I was like oh Jenny's
great yeah I was like Hey I just I saw
you post I'm I sent it in just to let
you know and then I was like this is
what the world
wants brother
son he cleared his schedule and then
[__] I started seeing you post hella
pictures of everyone and brother's son
I'm like I was not a part of that at all
Anthony Lee was in
it were you really in it or you [__]
with me I'm [__] with you shut the
[__] I believed he was in it I thought
he was I was like you never you I was
like episode 2 through six cuz he's only
seen episode one tell you until now I
don't know I thought he was like that I
thought he like that though every person
that walked in the room I was like you
know Anthony Lee was a brother's son he
didn't even tell us alarm man I'm
gullible
huh I actually started off um doing
YouTube in middle school I did covers
back in that my friend yeah I I I wrote
some kind of sappy acoustic songs in
high school and then I fully kind of
transition my page into my first YouTube
video was um a liptin to AA LaVine
complicated with a friend that was like
my first thing check it out look what I
dm'd her oh Jenny see I ain't [__]
around dude I'm Taiwanese and I'm a
comedian I'm not auru at all I mean you
got to put your head shot she have kept
real she be like I'm Taiwanese and I'm a
bodybuilder how long ago was it uh
February 2022 and she goes I was like I
don't have an agent and a manager can I
still audition she goes yes please do
instructions are on the flyer I'm like
okay thank you I'll send it in by
tomorrow that's what I did and then I
think they forgot to call me or
something that's what it was they messed
up right it was that's what it was
that's what it was but can you talk to
him for season two yeah I got it what
was the role though do you remember
which role do you remember what your
lines were I assume it was Charles's
cousin or whatever the bald dude in the
kaspa that like you know what I'm
talking about no it was probably like
the main role you probably audition for
the lead no I don't think so I think it
was like a side role really do you still
have your sides do you have your um I
don't know I'm looking for on my stupid
phone cuz now that we have someone from
the show we can figure out how off you
were I can confirm so
funny I I meet I've met a ton of people
that audition for my character oh really
all the time most of the time it's
always been good um there was one time
at a party I I brought a friend and then
he was talking to him and they got into
the conversation and he's like oh yeah I
audition for Terren dude what the [__]
did that guy and then I was right like
there oh and we met oh yo what's up dude
no it was fine I love killing people
with kindness it's my favorite thing cuz
I already got it it's still murder but
okay first degree I love
dude have you gotten any other roles or
is this is your first big role or this
is my first thing wow so the story
behind that is um in Georgia I got
nothing in Georgia I was with an agency
but in here my my my acting credentials
I've done two commercials one is like an
insurance commercial where I'm just
holding a box I'm the Asian dude holding
a box and then the other one is a diet
commercial where uh bunch of friends are
on the couch and half my face oh that's
it and I've done short films I've done a
couple short films one that made it on
HBO Max nice which one's that what's it
called it's called net NE uh it means
yes in Korean a Korean dude takes a
white girl out on a date to a Korean
restaurant but he can't speak Korean and
just folds that's so funny it was a cool
concept and then I've never never done
extra work I've never I've never uh
played like a five and under like a
waiter or anything like that and I just
got a series regular jeez well done are
you like without actively training like
you you you took a ton of acting classes
I did in Georgia um I went to like class
for like a year um
but I I I just live and breathe it in
the sense of everything that I'm
watching you're just kind of like
picking up little things see that's what
you should have said instead of I'm
Taiwanese that's what it said dude I was
like in this you know in this woke era
they're like we're tired of white people
playing the Mexican guy so I was like oh
okay in this super woke era if they're
casting Taiwanese they want Taiwanese
yeah that's fair that helps I'm so I was
like okay you got to play the game so
I'm like hey I don't want to audition
for the Korean role or the [__] Sri
Lankan role I'm just want to be the
Taiwanese guy but she's just reading a
DM it's not like Pride this guy's like I
live in breathing I live in breathe
Taiwan you yeah that would have been
better I should have took a picture with
stinky to with my
mouth I don't have Hong Kong feet so
like I can be on set J give him another
shot come on Jenny reupload the
series start fresh you said without an
agent or manager manager it was an open
call it like same thing like Instagram
um I saw it and then a couple people
sent it to me and I saw the r and I was
like oh this it kind of fits me did you
self tape I self taped how'd you tape
you got to teach me these techniques
what' you do how you in case the world
tells me to do it again again yeah the
thing about self tape you you just I
mean as Loose as possible you use the
phone or you use the iPhone is
everything now it's iPhone's fine oh you
know who helped me too [__] Tes yeah
[__] me up probably having a good reader
helps why did he rewrite your Lin he
actually told me he actually set up the
light like this and then so he was like
make sure it shines behind you so you're
separated from the background he
sabotaged you dude and he was like uh
make sure you like stand on this side of
the frame did he ask to be in it with
you no he didn't but he actually he
actually gave me a buch of white voice
out there you know what I'm saying so he
trying to take time when these roles he
doing the unwoke stuff unwoke like
growing up I I played basketball but
then my schools were always too good I
was never good enough to play on the
team so through acting I got my starting
five like full circle thing so after you
were on brother Sun did a bunch of
agents and managers try to scoop you up
so Jenny um set me up with some meetings
and then I brought on some managers
through the show and then it it worked
out cuz I thought it was just like a
kind of like a good practice thing and
it was my first role like with Netflix
so I just I was in the Deep Waters so I
brought them on it worked out because
they ended up getting a negotiation that
was like worth the percentage cut and
everything like that are your managers
Jewish they're uh one's Korean one's um
Chinese yeah but Korean Jew Chinese Jew
okay how was it working with uh Justin U
and subin Choy great subin was one of my
um stunt doubles yeah tackles a cop
that's dope he tackles cop sub subin's
he was here last week yeah he's
hilarious and Justin he's a goofball
dude that's a stunt coordinator oh no
sorry I thought you me Justin chin oh no
I was thinking of Justin you yeah I love
Justin he's so nice and he took us to
like tan tactical wow like stuff that
you don't get to just
experience yeah yeah yeah I got to like
shoot some guns um um he took us to like
a driving range so I got to like sit and
the professional drivers it's
exhilarating did you get to drive too no
oh they just put you and you're like no
literally it's it's pretty scary was it
in his car no no no no like he took us
to a track that fool has a dope ass
drift car like a Mustang with a LS Swap
and a full
cage his his Artistry his choreography
is shown a lot through the show it's
like his own kind of writing through
through the stunts when you when you're
on set do you let everyone know this is
my first gig this is my first or you got
to pretend like oh yeah so many rules oh
where's the crafties at over there like
you got like do you is there a certain
demeanor you have to be on
set you know I guess
it's like who are you as a person you're
going to bring that demeanor but the
cool thing is everyone's kind of new
it's Michelle and then us kind of a new
like this is all of our kind of first
big role and so there was a little bit
of that and so everyone was kind of
excited and like you know like it's your
first day of school that's cool like
there's probably like that there's
probably like a a feeling of like of
camaraderie where it's like uh oh we're
all in this together and then as you
guys continue to like get more and more
successful you probably be like I
remember that guy we all started like
here or whatever the dop the uh the
director used to be a dancer Kevin
tanton yeah how's it working with shout
out to Kevin oh I love Kevin the first
day of work my very first day of work um
and mind you like with no acting
experience in the certain like a set
right it was in front of like 200 people
cuz it was a club scene so there's a
bunch of extras and not to ruin movie
Magic but in a club scene there's no
music playing when you're shooting
awkward so it's just like a beach TR but
then me and um Bruce the character were
at the and we still have to talk in club
voice we're like hey what's up and so
that was my first day of work on a
Netflix production and then you know he
had cut and he came up to me gave Sam
some notes he turned to me and he was
like I think you have TK understood just
keep doing you and that just gave
me oh my my head was huge but it gave me
the confidence that's amazing yeah cuz
then that's going to make you Excel yeah
and so like that set the precedent and
and oh Kevin's great director great wow
Kevin's great I mean that's what a
director Kevin Teton you guys ever
watched like on YouTube years ago there
was just like this almost like a
fan-made remake of like Mortal Kombat
series he did that he did that no way
that [__] was tight yeah but he's a
dancer he used to dance and Cho for
Britney and then he would just back in
that that age he would just bring a
[__] like old school camcorder and
just like you know videotape like BTS
and then he put like a mini like cut
together and then suddenly it was like
this is amazing so the his like game
just evolved from organically shooting
[__] with on like the Britney tour and
stuff like that Co oh one thing before I
for sorry not to transition from Kevin I
was the first person cast on the entire
show really they chose you first Jenny
Jew baby major they liked you the best
she's Jewish Jenny Jewish yeah Jenny
they just saw you and they're like oh
this guy is him like right I submitted
in like the 11th Hour like I I
unintentionally um but yeah that's a big
deal thr
me on set like behind the scenes was
there any mention of Bart at all like
yeah they say like no one said his name
like even in passing self tape got
around said it went viral within the
yeah oh Jenny just text Jenny just
texted me too no way Jenny never text
me I love that she just harded we're
going to get bar on it
dude